it's exactly a week since the nationwide
lockdown policy was introduced so how do
we judge if it's working the number of
people who've now died from covert 19
has reached 1415 and the number of
deaths will increase every day until the
epidemic begins to reverse so it's best
to look at the growth rate how many days
it's taking for total deaths to double
in the early days it was doubling every
two days but this increase of 180 deaths
to 1415 is fewer than the 209 announced
yesterday and in line with what we have
seen in recent day suggesting a growth
rate of doubling around three days
although it's likely to be another week
or two before the changes show in the
figures today the chief scientific
advisors at Patrick violence presented
new information showing the impact of
the lockdown
let's start with this graph and the
effect it is having on transport it
shows how dramatically the number of car
train bus and two journeys have
decreased he also said the fat hospital
admissions appear to be stabilizing is
encouraging this graph shows the number
of kovat 19 admissions has reached 9,000
and the NHS is admitting an additional
1000 patients a day however Sir Patrick
valence says that number is now stable
and this final graph comparing UK deaths
to the rate in other countries bears out
our evidence that deaths are now
doubling every three days slower than
Italy was at this stage that's this blue
line and similar to France the yellow
line here so a slight flattening the
government says they are succeeding in
limiting the spread of the virus but it
will still be a couple of weeks before
we know for sure